qui
[Musique]
la plage la mer n'est pas la papauté
paysager du sud et non des images sont
plutôt celle d'une plage en gaspésie je
ferai à cuba au mexique où ont fleuri
les gens depuis quelques jours on a créé
une petite fleuriste billets coûtent
rien on est très fier je fais un volet
qui fut quand même je l'estimé au cours
de nombreuses années dont je tenais on a
décidé d'investir assez massivement en
investissement de 70 mille dollars pour
mettre en valeur trois plages celle de
pabos de pabos mills et de newport
les élus espèrent créer un engouement
sur le plan récréotouristique mais aussi
améliorer la sécurité en eau mais aussi
des sauveteurs pour l'année puis les
gens apprécient beaucoup on a beaucoup
de commentaires positifs puis c'est
beaucoup pour la sécurité et puis ça va
emmener d'autres touriste ou si la
cagnotte du sort on arrive alors que
d'un jeune elle aussi faite lors on est
venu passer une petite journée
c'est bien beau les plages sont propres
c'est bien aménagé est à des toilettes
qui est proche
l'achalandage est au rendez vous sur les
plages mais aussi ailleurs à chandler
les hôtels sont pleines même au niveau
du trafic sur les routes on voit un
achalandage assez marqué dernièrement il
ya quand même un effort on voit des
niveaux commerce niveau petit café le
café de jean-michel od fait partie de
cette vague de nouveaux commerces
le jeune propriétaire veut participer au
développement de sa communauté de la
gaspésia yeux fermés
appliqués les années avant
se reprenne en main il y avait lavé les
chaleurs percée faudrait que les gens
pensaient droite sean lam depuis
quelques années avec nouvelle lumineux
et ouvert il ya deux ans les petits
commerces chaîne l'a déjà les jeunes
boxeuses avec des projets comme la mise
en valeur des plages les conseillers
municipaux veulent continuer de
revitaliser le secteur et dès l'an
prochain j'espère que le musée de la
bolduc fermé depuis 2010 est pourra à
nouveau accueillir des visiteurs ici les
abos inde radio-canada cancun chandler